Today is pre-production for this video Jake wants to shoot tomorrow
which means that we're shooting it in here therefore
we have to move all the desks
somewhere else
Which is really annoying cause I like my desk where it is
I didn't say it was
GOTCHA
You and your suction cup
hands
you have a few more to go buddy
Now we're even
Dude! check this out
this is the printer, look how small this thing is
This is the spool of plastic it feeds into this and melts here then squirts out & makes a little things
The *uh* - No, that's a M
That's not a M
It's more of an M then an E
*Uhh, uh* (in the background) I disagree
Have you seen Tesla Model 3?
*laughs*
The movie "MEEE"
Mission Impossible 3
Yeah, it's an M
It's stands for mono price
The "MP"
Niko, Hey
Niko - "I left set just so I can see your printer"
*laughs*
This is the
This is not the
That's an M
YOU JUST CONFIRMED THAT YOU SAID IT
So if you don't know much about 3D Printers we have some videos to watch from our previous year
This thing is $200
This is as cheap as an Ink Jet printer that you get at best-buy
consumer level pricing for 3D printing so I was like "I have to have one"
I always knew someday that I would get into 3D printing, myself with my own personal printer and the day as finally come & this is it
Carmichael - "Now wait until it prints a new Wren"
To do all the effects for you and takes your money and your wife and your dog
Wren - "That's okay"
I have done nothing with it, I literally pulled it out of the box, plugged it in, put the SD card in and started printing
So what it does is it take a thousand cross sections of 3D model and lays that down
Here's a Yoda
This is the second thing I printed and it printed flawlessly
*Wren kisses Yoda*
This thing has been going on non-stop since I got it Sunday night basically every night while I sleep it prints then everyday when I'm at the studio it prints then I come back home, rinse and repeat
This is an elliptical gear
There is no central axis to this and they're not round but yet they're still operating like a normal gear
This is probably the coolest thing I printed so far
It looks like a bunch of cubes, you can't get too close and you have to be straight on
If I turn it on it's side, it's all in your head
Wren - "Niko, there is a couple like kind of big named actors in this show"
Those girls that were in other big shows and stuff I don't know if I can say their names
Nick - "The actors from the show"
Wren - "The actors from the show"
Like Mehhgeh
Famous people, what's it like working with someone  who's like I've been in alot of stuff you've seen me in
but we need to be professional
Wren in the background - "How do you be professional if you wanna geek out"
Niko - "Uh eh, I don't geek out"
*laugh*
So it's my job like actually make sure they're doing what I need them to do and delivering the proper story beats that we need to get
but they're also very good at it so I basically let them walk on set I go "Can I see it" and they do the scene and I'm like "That's pretty cool"
and that's about the extent of what I do
*Niko laughs*
Wren - I mean, I'm not surprised about that
Niko - "Mostly what I do is tell them when to change it up"
Cool you got it we nailed it
let's do something funky now, try this
Wren - "Like what's the biggest difference between like a good like expensive actor versus a non-good actor"
Niko - "A good actor knows all the things that happen around acting"
We are shooting six pages a day
And at that speed we can only do about 3 takes
The takes need to be good from the first take
We'll do some rehearsals before hand before the cameras roll
Once the cameras start rolling
The person needs to be on and in character
not screwing up their lines
good enough to roll back and like hit the line again if something funky happens
like.. if a plane flies by or something.
So a good actor makes you work fast
most of my direction on set is honestly just pushing  people
to just get into the emotions a little bit more
it's hard to commit to painful emotions if you are doing a sad scene, you know
and they'll do a good job
getting into it at a base level
and to sometimes, nope go a little harder, dove a little bit deeper into your internal sorrows
Carmichael - "like, you're on the right track you're doing what you are supposed to do but you're not hitting it keep going
Niko - "Yep"
Wren - "If you put a light in here"
It'll project light out as squares on the ground around it
Carmichael - "You did it"
Wren - "Look at this!"
A $200 printer printed this
and it's for all intents and purposes flawless
if you don't count all the flaws
Let's see if my phone light will work
Hey! actually holy crap
that works really well
look at these square lights
*Wren making noises*
I've made square light
it's important to note that I haven't actually modeled  any of these things myself
I've literally been downloading them from a website called Thingiverse
What would you even call it? Everyone can kind of user submit their own...
*someone in background* "Universe of things
*Wren chuckles*
Wren - "Like all of these models are free models that you can download, people have just donated them to this website"
Here is this like Baby Groot
and I've loaded it up in this program called "Cura"
You have a program that you model stuff in but then you need another program or plugin
that can take that model and make it ready for printing
support structures and putting into the right format for the printer to read
it's going to print the head and the body of Baby Groot separately
Wren - "Thank you"
Wren - "Let's set this up right here"
Plug that in, take this
THIS IS NOT A SPONSOR LIKE AT ALL
this is actually something I'm really, really interested in
This, this is like really cool
Wren - "So once this heat's up to 210 degrees"
it's going to start laying a bed of plastic and that's called a "raft"
Baby Groot will literally just sit on that
Wren - "This is the first little bit!"
*someone in the background* "Groot Root"
Wren - "GROOT ROOT AHA GROOT ROOT"
Yeah, so this should uh take
maybe three hours
we'll come back in three hours
QUEUE THE TIME LAPSE
Niko - "I basically have three sets of directing that I approach"
I have
my directing for the actor
which is the decisions of making as a character
the important emotional beats
you might saying "Thank you" but you really mean inside is "F*ck you"
Nick - "So like sub-text"
Niko - "Yeah sub-text"
you know like things like that
a good actor already has all the stuff prepped
the other directing I need to do is for
the crew and the camera
saying "Okay I need this set decorated like this, I'm looking for this kind of temperature on the lights,
props in the background need to be here,
let's put the camera over here"
so basically crew all the direction
Carmichael - "the 1st ad's responsiblity?"
it's his responsibility but I communicate through him
Wren - "Most of the time you talk to ad you don't actually talk to the gaffers and the prop positioners specifically"
Niko - "I'll be like I'm looking for this, I'm looking for this, I'm looking for this"
then he's the guy who goes makes it happen
when it comes to camera team I talk to the director of photography, he talks to the camera team
so I talk to Adrian, he talks to the camera team and the lighting team and the group team
and my third and final level of directions, audience direction
at the beginning of the scene
I want people to think everything's fine and dandy
and by the end of the scene I want the audience to realize that there is a much bigger problem that no-one has realized
so then I need to make sure that my whole scene plays into that story direction or that audience direction, what the audience is going to take away
and sometimes I'll share that with the actors and be like
I want the audience to take away from the scene
that you guys truly love each other
that you really want to focus on making each other laugh make each other cry
smiling like all that kinda stuff
that's my direction for the audience and I'll share that with people if I need to
Wren - "I don't know, I have no idea"
I've never dealt with foggers.. before
wait, what?
the f-f fogger that we used before was
NOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Nick - "Come on"
Wren - 'That's twice in one day!"
Carmichael - "OH HE GOT YOU"
*clap*
Wren - "Alright so it's done"
it took an hour and 49 minutes
little Baby Bear
so I'm going to go ahead and just peel it off the bed with my fingertips
ARGH there we go
Ahh, look he's got string sticking out of his eye
I literally halved the size
Spencer - "Way smaller of a print bed"
little bit of a slower print time
but....
for the frickin' price
Wren - "Regardless of price I feel that this is a pretty good quality print"
Spencer - "I which our printer was working so I can print something we could literally compare-"
Wren - "compare it"'
but the problem is my printer won't finish
so there is no comparison to be made
Wren - "Dude"
moment of truth
I'm going to put the head on......
ahhh, it's got a little groove in there to make sure it goes in at the right angle
A Groot Groove, aahahah
LOOK AT THAT LITTLE BABY GROOT
An hour and a half print on the
*Wren breaks BABY GROOT!*
Wren - "I just broke it!"